but we have a special guest in studio
yeah as one of our favorite guests here
at the st. Louis chess club
that's right kitty Rock with the
president of explore st. Louis is with
Maurice well if you want to come to st.
Louis this is the woman to talk to
because she knows everything there is to
know what if you know all the hidden
gems are under the city yeah yeah we
tricked you with that well I think it's
gonna be a trick question I'm in trouble
I do know about the caves is that what
you're talking no I don't know anything
about anything under the city that's
what I'm just you know we talked so
often that I'm looking for something new
and DIF I'm gonna get you with that one
today just saw the movie us and there
were some things in there about under
the city but Kitty Radcliffe president
of explore st. Louis also named one of
the most influential business women in
the city so I stopped here Oh power lady
first for those who don't know about
explosion st. Louis tell us a bit about
its mission we're a sales and marketing
organization essentially talking about
st. Louis as a place to visit and as you
know we have a lot of great assets here
that make it a great visitor destination
so have a great job tell us what's
coming up what's what's the next thing
happening in the city in the next couple
of months well is you know this time of
year is like you know it's an explosion
of fun things happening every single day
getting ready for the Opera Theatre
season and Shakespeare in the Park
Festival that goes on every year in
Forest Park and circus floor all of
those things are coming up in May and in
June it's really exciting time something
fun to do at you know every single day
that you spall of course baseball well
of course there's baseball you know
every st. was a know so the Cardinals
baseball is part of our DNA so opening
day is a few weeks away for home games
there at the Cardinals are actually
opening up away so tonight I'm gonna go
see Justin Timberlake Oh sounds like fun
yeah that'll be that'll be great as well
as you guys have so much stuff to do
here
that said you must have some challenges
on this job like what are your biggest
challenges when you when you're working
with such a by the whole city and trying
to keep everybody entertained all the
time yeah well well keeping people
entertained is easy you know when I we
look at our regional economy and
everything that we have to offer there
you know there's just something fun for
people to do every single day and it
really doesn't matter what your interest
is because we can meet your needs I
think you know the biggest challenge is
kind of cutting through the clutter of
everybody trying to tell the story about
their cities and positioning st. Louis
in such a way that it would kind of
break through that and interest people
and coming here because we find when
they do come here they have an
extraordinary experience people who come
here for chess tournaments may not come
for any other reason except for that but
when they get here they find everything
that there is to do and it sends them
home as ambassadors for our community so
you know how do we find those essential
things that help us cut through the
space and the noise of people
advertising other cities tell me now
about underground
you said someone I'd never heard of
these caves
I love caves what's up with that well
that's why that's why st. Louis was a
big brewery town that's why
anheuser-busch and Lemp brewery and you
know all of the historical breweries
were here it's because they they built
their breweries along the Mississippi
River and the caves from the river
underneath kept a cool place for them to
keep the beer this was in pre
refrigeration days so there are parts of
the city that are built on caves it's
quite extraordinary actually and some of
them they will open from time to time
for you to go down and take a tour that
way I hear those spooky sounds you know
know that hotel is haunted that's that's
another story
[Laughter]
you hear those noises what the heck was
that actually there's one of the one of
the old brewery families that I just
mentioned the Lemp family it's not a
brewery anymore but the Lemp mansion is
still there and three of the members of
the Lemp family committed suicide in
that mansion it is haunted and you can
stay there if you want oh yeah did you
learn chess yet ladies night here wine
cheese chess no I'm waiting for Jennifer
to invite me you know Kitty's been
coming from with us so many years as a
friend and of course as the boss lady
running explore st. Louis kitty thank
you so much for all you do for the city
thank you and so sparse your website
explore st. Louis comm pretty darn easy
enough there you go absolutely come on
down to this great city and enjoy chess
and of course everything there is to do